This lecture is about the syntagmatic
relation discovery.
An entropy.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue talking about word Association
mining.
In particular, we can talk about how to
discover syntagmatic relations.
And we're going to start with the
introduction of entropy, which is the
basis for designing some measures for
discovering such relations.
By definition, Syntagmatic relations
hold between words that have correlated
Co occurrences.
That means when we see one word occurs
in the context, we tend to see the
occurrence of the other word.
So take a more specific example, here
we can ask the question whenever eats
occurs, but other words also tend to
occur.
Now looking at the sentence is on the
left.
We see some words that might occur
together with eats like a cat, dog or
fish
is right.
But if I take them out and if you look
at the right side where we only show
eats and some other words.
The question that is, can you predict
what other words occur?
To the left or to the right.
Right, so this would force us to think
about what other words are associated
with eats.
If they are associated with eats, they
tend to occur in the context of eats.
So more specifically, our prediction
problem is to take any text segment,
which can be a sentence, paragraph or a
document, and then I asked the question
is a particular word present or absent
in this segment.
Right here we can ask the question
about the world W is present or absent
in this segment.
Now, what's interesting is that some
words are actually easier for it, in
other words.
If you take a look at the three words
shown here, meet, the and Unicorn.
Which one do you think it is easier to
predict?
Now, if you think about it for a
moment, you might conclude that.
The is easier to predict because it
tends to occur everywhere, so I can
just say with the in the semtence.
Unicorn is also relatively easy.
Because Unicorn is rare, is very rare.
And I can bet that it doesn't occur in
this sentence.
But meat is somewhere in between in
terms of frequency, and it makes it
hard to predict because it's possible
that it occurs in the sentence or the
segment more accurately.
But it may also not occur in the
segment.
So now let's start this problem more
formally.
Alright, so the problem can be formally
defined as predicting the value of a
binary random variable.
Here we denoted by X sub w, w denotes
a word.
So this random variable is associated
with precisely one word.
When the value of the variable is 1, it
means this word is present.
When it's zero, it means the word is
absent, and naturally the probabilities
for one and zero should sum to 1.
Because a word is either present or
absent in the segment.
There's no other choice.
So the intuition we discussed earlier
can be formally stated as follows.
The more random this random variable
is, the more difficult the
prediction would be.
Now the question is, how does one
quantitatively measure the randomness
of a random variable like X sub w, how in
general, can we quantify the randomness
of a variable?
And that's why we need a measure called
entropy.
And this is a measure introduced in
information theory to measure the
randomness of X.
There is also some connection with the
information here, but that's beyond the
scope of this course.
So for our purpose we just treat the
entropy function as a function defined
on a random variable.
In this case it's a binary random
variable, although the definition can
be easily generalized for a random
variable with multiple values.
Now the function form looks like this.
There's a sum over all the possible
values for this random variable inside
the sum,
for each value we have a product of the
probability that the random variable
equals this value and log of this
probability.
And note that there is also an negative
sign there.
Now, entropy in general is not negative
and that can be mathematically proved.
So if we expand this sum will see the
equation looks like a second one I
explicitly plugged in the two values
zero and one.
And sometimes when we have 0 log of 0,
we would generally find that as zero
because log of 0 is undefined.
So this is the entropy function and
this function will give a different
value for different distributions of
this random variable.
And this clear it clearly depends on
the probability that the random
variable taking a value of one or zero.
If we plotted his function
against the probability that the random
variable is equal to 1
and then the function looks like this.
At the two ends,
That means when the probability of X =
1 is very small or very large, then the
entropy function has a lower value when
it's .5 in the middle that it reaches
the maximum.
Now, if we plot the function against
the probability that the X
is taking a value of 0 and the
function would show exactly the same
curve here.
And you can imagine why and so
that's because
the two probabilities are symmetric
and completely symmetric.
So an interesting question.
You could think about in general
here is for what kind of X?
Does the entropy reached maximum or
minimum and we can in particular think
about some special cases.
For example, in one case we might have
a random variable that
always takes the value of one,
the probability is
one
or there is a random variable that
Is equally likely taking a value of 1
or 0.
In this case, the probability that X =
1 is .5.
Now, which one has a higher entropy?
It's easier to look at the problem by
thinking of simple example.
Using coin tossing,
so when we think about the random
experiment like a tossing a coin,
it gives us a random variable that
can represent the result.
It can be head or tail, so we can
define a random variable X sub coin so
that it's one when the coin shows up as
head, it's zero when the coin shows up
as tail.
So now we can compute the entropy of
this random variable, and this entropy
indicates how difficult it is to
predict the outcome of a coin for coin
tossing.
So we can think about the two cases.
One is a fair coin, it's completely
fair.
The coin shows up as head hotel equally
likely, so the two probabilities would
be,
1/2 right so both will have both equal
to 1/2.
Another extreme case is completely
biased coin, where the coin always
shows up as head, so it's a completely
biased coin.
Now let's think about the entropies in
the two cases, and if you plug in these
values you can see the entropies,
would be as follows for a fair coin we
see the entropy reaches its maximum,
that's one.
For the completely biased coin we see
is 0 and that intuitively makes a lot
of sense because a fair coin is most
difficult to predict
whereas a completely biased coin is
very easy to predict that we can always
say it's a head because it is a head all
the time so they can be shown on the
curve as follows.
So the fair coin corresponds to the
middle point, or it's very uncertain.
The completely biased coin corresponds
to the end point.
We have a probability of 1.0 and the
entropy is 0.
So now let's see how we can use entropy
for word prediction.
Now the problem, let's think about our
problem right, still predicted whether
W is present or absolutely in this
segment.
Again, think about the three words.
Particularly, think about their
entropies.
Now we can assume high entropy words
are harder to predict.
And so we will now have quantitative
way to tell us which word is harder to
predict.
Now if you look at the three words,
meat, the and Unicorn again.
An we clearly would expect the meat to
have a high entropy, then the OR
Unicorn.
In fact, if you look at the entropy of
the,
It's close to 0,  because
it occurs everywhere.
So, it's like a completed biased coin,
therefore the entropy is 0.